قال رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
انه سيتم توجيه الاتهام اليه في ثلاث
وثلاثين تهمه في محكمه نيويورك اليوم
الثلاثاء واعتبر ترامب ان مدعي العام في
منحاه سرب لائحه الاتهام لوسائل اعلام كما
اشر رئيس الامريكي السابق اشار الى انه لا
توجد تغييرات او مفاجات او انه غير مذنب
مؤكدا ايضا انه يجب توجيه رائحه اتهام الى
المدعي العام نفسه حيث تسربت محتويات
لوائح الاتهام المعلقه الى الصحافه وردنا
على مطالب وسائل اعلام بالسماح لها ببث
المحاكمه على الهواء
اكد القاضي
اليوم ان محاكمه الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب لن تداعى الهواء مباشره القادم
على اهميه هذه المحاكمه التاريخيه ومؤكدا
انه سيتم استمعه فقط لبعض المصورين
بالتقاط صور في قاعه المحكمه قبل بدء
الاجراءات رسميا
هذا وافاد محامي الدفاع عن الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب جو تاكوبينا
ان موكله يعتزم اعلان براءته امام محكمه
نيويورك وانشاء الوحيد الذي سيتم الاجابه
عليه على الفور هو انهم سيقولون بانه غير
مذنب على حد وصفه واضافت كوبينا ان تقييم
ودراسه لائحه الاتهام وتحديد الاجراءات
بعد تلقي جميع المعلومات ستستغرق وقتا كما
يعتقد محامي ترامب ان القضيه سخيفه من
نواحي كثيره وانها تعد اضطهادا سياسيا على
حد وصفه وشددا على ان القضيه تدخل منطقه
خطيره حيث السياسه لها تاثير على نظام
العداله وتستخدم النيابه العامه كسلاح
ايضا